when he was deputy minister of health
pavlov koftunyuk tried to reform the
ukrainian health system
and now three years later he's
documenting its destruction
this was once the cardiology center of
chernyhu
but in march a russian air raid reduced
it to rubble
that was just one of over 180 attacks on
health facilities documented by
koptonyuk and his ngo
i see the systemic pattern of
destruction of healthcare
as a part of civilian livelihood because
it's not only about healthcare it's all
types of civilian objects are being
systemically targeted
a dash cam video recorded the moment
when eight russian bombs hit this
residential area
a witness sent us another video it shows
the devastation just minutes after the
impact
and the crater right in front of the
cardiology center is clear to see
47 people died in the attack and dozens
were injured
one resident told us about how shells
were raining down non-stop on chernohew
back then
[Applause]
they needed excavators the victims all
had to be buried in body bags
witnesses confirmed there were no
military facilities or positions of any
kind near the hospital
that's why captain says the attack was a
war crime and that russia must be held
accountable
understood hospitals are the places
which military should seek to avoid
actively it's not that they would shell
and say oh sorry that was a hospital no
they should check if a hospital is there
and if it is there they should do
anything possible not to hit that it's
their obligation according to
geneva conventions
but to ensure justice is served they're
trying to gather as much evidence as
possible
coptoniuk and his colleagues have been
in the field talking to witnesses and
looking for traces of impacts and pieces
of ammunition
and they're meticulously documenting the
damage
says they're following international
standards
so that courts worldwide can use their
evidence
we are not legal people by background
none of us we are healthcare people but
we got some trainings in those protocols
and those procedures and we are using
the software to do our best and hoping
for at least a part of that
evidence will
go and will win in in some case
and his ngo has also documented the case
of chanahu's pediatric hospital
we spoke with dr mikola yudkevich
we could ask him any questions he just
started talking about what happened
and about how they were treating all the
people injured in an attack on the
residential area
and how their hospital itself was hit by
a bomb two weeks later
we're trained trauma surgeons but we've
never experienced these kinds of
bleeding wounds everyone was screaming
adults and children
we put five of them on the floor but
they just kept coming it was complete
with shells raining down they had to
flee into the basement again and again
they even did surgery there and did
their best to protect the children until
the hospital itself was hit
the russian missiles were equipped with
cluster munition
largely banned under an international
treaty
they impacted the first to the fifth
floor
fortunately there was an air raid siren
before the cluster bomb hit
so we got the kids into the basement
otherwise we would have had 237
fatalities
he showed us the pieces of shrapnel he
collected on site
it would have taken them hours to remove
the dozens of bits of shrapnel from the
children's bodies
when you hear this it's no need to
explain why we need
justice
because somebody needs to pay
for
what was done to the to people like
like nicola
or his patients
as we left chernahu again we passed by
another fully destroyed hospital
koptonyuk knows it could take years for
legal action to be taken in
international courts
but in the meantime he wants to do
anything he can to collect evidence